hello in this video I'll talk about
apoptosis or programmed cells there
so cells need to grow they need to
divide and they need to form more cells
in order to support the growth of an
organism but not only the birth and the
growth of the cell is important also the
death of the cell is very important and
the cell death is occurring at a highly
regulated and a stepwise fashion it's
not a haphazard process and the process
by which it is regulated events would
lead to cellular death is known as
apoptosis now you might think that cell
death is not a good event but it is very
important for a lifestyle the life cycle
of a cell because if it is immortal then
diseases like cancer could happen where
uncontrolled division and proliferation
can give rise to tumor formation and
thereby delete and that lead to cancer
so cancer cells are literally immortal
so they somehow evade the process of
apoptosis
that means the program cell there so
they don't die so that's a bad event so
that is why learning about apoptosis is
so important and also this if the
apoptosis is an enzyme regulated process
because it's pretty regulated now the
key enzyme that helps in this process is
known as caspase and the name is
abbreviation for system dependent
aspartate directed protease so it's a
system it's its it belongs to the family
of the cysteine protease and also leaves
after the aspartate residue in the
target protein and it cleaves the target
port protein by a subsequent
nucleophilic attack so caspase can
activate several other dangerous
proteins which are normally dormant
inside the cell the
DNA's rnase and proteases so normally
these proteins are dormant inside the
cell but gas-phase can activate them and
thereby overall destruction program
could be initiated inside a cell so the
the fact that the cell would die the
signal or the order that the cell should
die right now should come from either
inside or it can come from outside let's
talk about when the signal for apoptosis
is coming from the inside the intrinsic
signal for apoptosis the intrinsic
signal of apoptosis generally contains
irreparable DNA damage or
double-stranded DNA
break let's say so the DNA damage has to
be detected by specific proteins like
ATM or ATR those are kinase and tumor
suppressor gene p53 try to understand
that what is the degree of damage if it
is the repeatable damage it would halt a
cell cycle progression of the cell
division and give the cell time to
reboot its own activity or repair its
DNA but if the damage is fatal
then p53 would activate pax
or increase the transcription of beck's
now Beck's is a protein which can form
poor on the might called mitochondrial
membrane and in the mitochondrial
membrane the reciter chrome see which
leaks out from this pore now cytochrome
c is a component of the electron
transport system or electron transport
chain which generates the ATP now ATP is
important for the cell it's a power
house of the cell that mitochondria is
the powerhouse of the cell and the ATP
is the energy currency so cytochrome C
is not there the electron carrier is
missing the ATP cannot be produced that
is one type of harm but this is not the
last cytochrome C once out in the
cytosol can interact with other proteins
like a path one together with a puff one
it can activate caspases cytochrome C
and a puff one together can activate
initiator caspases like s8 or caspase-9
and know
normally these guest spaces are also in
an inactive form that are triggered and
activated by opportunity cleavage once
the initiator caspases are active they
also activate subsequent executors
caspase and most commonly the executors
caspases caspase-3 once the executors
caspase is activated it will ensure the
cell would die by na by cleaving the DNA
or by cleaving the cytoskeletal element
overall cytoskeleton breakdown would
happen now extrinsic signal of apoptosis
could occur outside the cell now we take
a specific example of how a virus
infected cell is destroyed by a
cytotoxic T cell so there the extrinsic
signal is viral entry or viral infection
let's say this cell in the middle the
yellow cell is infected by the virus and
the viral proteins gone inside they are
translated using the host cell machinery
and this translated viral protein are
processed in class 1 MHC inside the
endoplasmic reticulum and displayed on
the cell surface the cytotoxic C T cell
the cd8 positive cytotoxic T cell can
recognize that and they can secrete
perforin and granzymes which would
ultimate induce the apoptotic pathway
now here is the blue which is the T's T
cell and the yellow is the cells that
are that is virus infected now the power
14 and the granzymes are getting inside
the cell powerfully nanograms i'm or
foreign form a port by which prancin can
come out and granzymes can activate
several proteins through apoptotic
proteins like feedbacks pad etcetera
which all lead to leak of cytochrome c
in the cytosol that ultimately activates
inactive caspase-3 to caspase cleaved
caspase-3 and crease cleaved caspase-3
can lead
to apoptosis other way there are several
receptor and ligand interaction fast L
and fast mediated interactions on the
surface which can activate proteins such
as activated such as inactive gas space
and they can cleave that to form an
activated caspase-8 that ultimately
leads to gas with reproduction and leads
to apoptosis now in this example we saw
the signal for killing the cell or a
program cell death has been originated
outside of the cell and that the signal
was infection by the virus and by a
caspase mediated coordinated fashion the
cell is dying and the ultimate outcome
is pricking of the cytoskeletal breaking
out the architecture of the cell and the
cell will die forming clips which
contains fragmented DNA protein and it's
cytoskeletal elements so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked my video
give it a big thumbs up tune in to
lecture and subscribe thank you